hey everybody it's Kevin Bernard here I
stopped by the GameSpot offices and
thought I'd personally deliver to you
what I think at this preliminary stage
about The Witcher 3 blood and wine
Geralt of Rivia is not primarily known
for his humor nor is The Witcher series
itself but a wicked jocularity has
always course through The Witcher 3 and
its predecessors the residents of this
unforgiving world must find pleasure
wherever they can even if only in a sly
wise crack or a groan worthy pun some
might make it sing out loud and clear
how much let's say 500 crowns what gotta
be kidding me in The Witcher threes
final expansion blood and wine he were
no longer lurks in the shadows it steps
into the Sun winking and nudging you
towards the next quest with surprising
anachronism and self-awareness yet The
Witcher threes ability to surprise
should not be so surprising after all CD
Projekt RED has consistently proven its
ability to rethink and recontextualize
returning ideas and themes to say
something new about this world and its
inhabitants second straight up being my
bet look the window and to be head to
the sky let us please but we should be
here to winter I can't say whether the
humor is entirely successful I'm not yet
finished with blood and wine which I had
estimate to be about the length of The
Witcher 2
judging from the pace of level
progression I've actually found the
jokes distracting from time to time
blatant references to the real world
have a habit of yanking you out of the
fantasy and yet I couldn't stay mad for
long not when the payoffs were so
memorable the game is breaking of the
fourth wall had me rolling my eyes at
first only to make me joyful over the
inside I'd gained later on I may never
think of Roche the same way again
humor may take a prominent role but
blood and wine is still tumultuous both
in and out of its primary tale again
your choices have meaningful and often
unpredictable consequences such as a
quest involving a cursed creature and a
house full of spoons it's been a day
since I completed that quest yet I'm
still thinking about the truth I found
there and the punishment its primary
character endured was it rightful
punishment I'm not sure but I've spent a
good time contemplating whether my good
choice was well and truly good and shall
sit and dine with you at your table no
spoon you have shall say to you never
again shall you wish to spy your
reflection in the mirror I do miss the
old gang however blood and wine has a
dearth of sorceresses and Dwarfs though
no shortage of horrific creatures to
slay and certainly no shortage of quests
to take things can get a bit repetitive
a few dally on one quest line for too
long solving the problems of a couple of
vineyards becomes a boring cycle of
fighting the same monsters in different
areas
luckily even the rare on exciting quests
can yield welcome rewards one of which
is the DTR own upgradeable vineyard in a
state don't expect fallout 4 levels of
customization blood and wine is more
similar to Far Cry primal in this regard
presenting a series of automated
improvements that cost a certain amount
of cash blood and wine also introduces a
supplementary mutation system as a quest
reward for a melancholy storyline it's a
smart mechanic opening up new
possibilities once you've no reason to
spend skill points on upgrades you
either won't use or have no slot for
you'll certainly be glad for the passive
improvements during the tougher
encounters which are much more taxing
than before
sometimes exhaustively so be prepared to
rethink your strategy when living
statues pepper the ground with magical
traps or when giant centipedes rise from
the earth to surround you and don't
forget to save from time-to-time blood
and wines checkpoints don't always work
in your favor
blood and wine is outrageously beautiful
it's new region Tucson takes the air of
the French countryside though its skies
are bluer its foliage is more lush and
its rolling hills are more impressive
it's as close to high fantasy this dark
fantasy series has gotten and it's all
the better for it it says if the witcher
two's elven rose garden had been
expanded to continental proportions
every rose has its thorns however dank
caves Harbor terrible beasts and
cemeteries shelter the most horrid of
two songs residents the creepiest
accordion tunes you've ever heard SERP 2
underlined the horror it's not a
surprise given the witcher 3 is
consistently excellent audio
notwithstanding a few too many glitches
where Geralt speaks over himself when
you activate multiple triggers at once
nice tune indeed there's more to say
about the witcher 3 blood and wine of
course and i'll have a full review for
you once i finished for now however i
can confirm what you likely guessed
blood and wine is quite good quite big
and quite likely to make you glad to
return to one of videogames most
engaging worlds damn it
you